bill warcola stands out in front of his
home on main street sorting through the
small mountain of what's left of his
possessions
it's everybody's partial blinds except
that flooded stuff that was under water
this is all in basement this is
generally everybody's basement his
basement filled up with water and is now
a muddy mess with what little he could
salvage and it totally filled up with
water and flooded it comes above the
floor above us when i first moved here
cola has lived in the town of manville
new jersey his entire life 68 years and
seen five different floods this was the
worst you see the garage is the peep out
sign yep you see the black line yep so
this is this flood the water level was
here
as bad as it looks from the ground the
true scale of the destruction can only
be seen from the air a few days ago
first the town flooded then gas line
breaks set some homes on fire
in manville population 10 000 it's
estimated 500 people are now displaced
after the remnants of hurricane ida came
through and flooded the town over the
weekend
in new jersey 27 people were killed
making it one of the worst natural
disasters in the state's history it came
with a vengeance it came so fast and so
high i've never seen it as high as
it came
ever
i've lived here all my life and i've
never seen the waters as high as they
were there was no
no warning they didn't sound sirens
until after the town started flooding
many residents told me the weather is
changing and for the worse they keep
telling us their hundred year storms
their 500 year storms whatever they tell
us but
is that really the case
you know
you look at look around i mean if this
is a hundred year storm and yes it works
on averages but
i think we're exceeding the average
quite a bit in this town you know the
storms are getting
more and more intense in the area
in a town that bore the brunt of a
deadly storm with a long recovery and
rebuilding process ahead
gabriel lozando al jazeera manville new
jersey